let's say we discovered life proximate
sary B so what do you think would happen
the next day and I'm not trying to be
like you know total Cassandra about this
but I said I don't think anything would
happen what are you talking about it be
transformational I'm like I stipulate
that life exists go down to the Pacific
Ocean scoop up a glass you're going to
find life in there and what are we doing
what are we doing to our Earth We're
destroying it let me take it a step
further how many people died in the 20th
century kill we kill we name we harm we
hurt we hate I don't think anything
happen the next day we go back to what
we had and I said if that weren't proof
enough life has been discovered at least
two or three times just in my
professional career we don't give a crap
so why are we thinking that like from
whence will our Salvation come as the
Bible says like it's not going to change
how we are it's not going to magnify how
I treat you or you treat me